[Music]
hey now welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for elf I'm special J
Gilbert s Joestar that's Dan Merrill
hello a happy holiday weekend to you all
we are back we have forgotten everything
that happened last week when we wrote
and created the honest trailer for elf
so this will be a fun experience yeah
nice one back like we're all watching it
together for the first time you'll get
our uncensored thoughts on the film and
I think you'll stick around to the end
because then you'll see some cut jokes
and deleted scenes and the such yeah
it's a good movie from what I recall it
is a holiday classic yeah I find it
delightful yep it's trailers to throw
back to kind of the older days of honest
trailers when there are some movies that
you only need about two and a half
minutes to tell the story of those
movies you know what you're getting I
think because if you'll recall
Thanksgiving weekend or they should I
say the trailer that comes out after
Thanksgiving as a spotty record because
I believe the infamous dawn of the
Planet of the Apes trailer it was the
worst I did was a Thanksgiving weekend
rush job yeah that would make sense and
there's only two days and then your day
the next one yeah that's why I should be
happy we cared to make one at all yeah
leftovers but that's why I think this is
a kind of a snack size you're like yeah
be quick and dirty and lean and mean and
we're gonna say we need to say we're
gonna get out cuz we don't want another
yeah and the funny thing here so that's
true yeah dirty elf though is a very
different movie yeah yeah don't that's
dirty grandpa to a whole dirty universe
yeah dirty Yukon kornelius yeah dirty
ratatouille Oh any money
dirty I like okay cool and they all have
dinero in it as the dirty grass as the
dirty thing yeah that would have been
fun dirty Goodfellas yeah it's still one
word but he's not the bad grandpa he's
just the dirty one right that's sure
okay right bad grandpa is Johnny
Knoxville right and dirty grandpa right
yeah
a dirty pop star yeah dirty pop
dirty pop yeah I like this so elf is a
film starring Will Ferrell where he is
that was kind of his introduction as a
movie star was elf yeah I mean he'd done
like night at the Roxbury and he'd been
in movies before but this was like his
co-lead from yeah or they weren't very
good this is like oh he can really he's
a movie star he can be a movie star yeah
and I remember seeing this movie and
liking it quite a bit and I still like
it this is one of two that I alternate
every year on Christmas Eve this movie
and Christmas vacation solid solid
Christmas cause yes I this movies felt
so like big that I thought this came
after Anchor Malik I thought anchorman
was his big splash because there's it
feels weird that like then your
Christmas movie is your big foray into
into feature films right there's a whole
parallel universe where he just became
the Christmas guy yeah he's doing like
less and less comedy and more and more
like he's the one doing all the weird
Netflix Christmas movies yeah yeah is
this the last classic Christmas movie
made oh he's like as far as like stable
unless you've seen it's like it's 15
years old but I think it's like I think
it's like the last classic movie because
there's nothing after it I mean did you
guys see the Christmas prints on Netflix
people are really good Allah do nuts
over that one it's really powerful
saying I have Billy says it goes into
his permanent rotation okay Chris maybe
that's a new one okay yeah I don't think
there's been anything post elf that's
like worthy not even a contender
maybe the Christmas rinser those are
that's bad kind of fun movies but uh
yeah no I can't
I'm sure somebody'll think of something
that we've forgotten yep but this is the
last one I remember being like out of
not like Four Christmases or something
and like people watch some people but
like this is a hallmark no pun intended
yeah so it's as good a Christmas
tradition to watch this one as any
yeah let's watch it now in the honest
truth hey hey and your question is why
do we do these not at Christmas it's
because they need to have a shelf life
because nobody cares after Christmas
except we're doing it a little before
some Christmas movies are sweet some are
funny super super weird thanks mr.
Narwhal
meet buddy and orphan abandoned by his
mom after a one-night stand
who's stolen by Santa raised by a family
who thinks he's a burden yeah I think
the stolen by Santa Point bears
repeating because he he crawls into
Santa's sack as it was a treasure you do
and come out of Santa's sack we're all
babies come from
but at that point Santa's like whoops or
he's not like whoops I stole a baby he
won the war I guess the baby's ours now
this baby belongs to me now it's like
Santa knows the exact geographical
location yeah of everyone and where
their presents go yeah he could return
that baby easily easily but he only
works one day it's one-way shipping you
know I'm just dropping off I don't take
back yeah but yeah by the by the Santa -
I think he buddy boned him he owed Bob
Newhart a favor
Oh like there was a weight like he did
something he did him a solid like way
back maybe something a little well he
hooked up the sleigh yeah yeah he pimped
out of sleigh yeah yeah so he owed him a
kid yeah yes yeah oh I can someone can
make the tallest of things so waiting
for another human I've always wondered
like cuz everyone's like oh he can't
make a Simon toy and this and that and
it's like there's got to be something
for a tall person to do with the North
Pole like he clean the roof he can put
the star on the top of the tree
yeah stack things I don't know man but I
don't know elf powers are a whole other
thing we'll get into it yeah keep
watching
raised by a family who thinks he's a
burden and gets sent to new york with
nothing but the clothes on his back to
find his real dad who thinks he's
mentally ill and wants nothing to do
with it I love you know how I got these
tights so it does seem like a weird that
weird alchemy of like this is - they're
jokers a new Joker take all it takes is
one bad day Christmas Day yeah one bad
Christmas day yeah I mean it's a dark
origin story for buddy but you know he's
a classic Pollyanna just just smiles in
the face of awfulness and it's right and
and doesn't he bowl us over with his
Christmas cheer he sure does man he
doesn't let he doesn't let it get to him
yeah yeah he had a bad day and he didn't
go kidnap a police commissioner shoot
his daughter he had a lot of bad days
yeah like quite a few know what testing
jack-in-the-boxes will do to a man oh
yeah all day every day I was reading
about that being a genuine reactions
because jon favreau who directed this
movie is a is triggering the
jack-in-the-box with a remote so he
would he would switch it up every day
genuine when Will Ferrell would be shots
terrifying yeah someone who hates
children yes they're supposed to scare
they scare the curses out of children
yeah that's why you get one every Goblin
it keeps the cursus in the box
let's give Cody boy a Will Ferrell
performance for the ages showing off his
infectious joy I just like to smile
smiling's my favorite
his physical comedy
we know that's probably a stunt double
in all senses Jim Carrey turned down
this role and did the Grinch instead as
he did the performance so balls to the
wall and saying you won't even care that
Zooey Deschanel hooks up with someone it
is a title
maybe the pause maybe some of his
timelessness comes to the fact that this
was a script that was going to be made
with Jim Carrey in the 90s and then got
stuck in a drawer until another Jim
Carrey another jr. came along to do it I
don't think this movie would have been
it would have been different with Jim
but like I think it speaks to like some
kind of timeless quality about it but
you could set this in any decade he
doesn't have a boyishness it's like an
empty Meharry yeah it's like a like it's
like a child yeah Jim Carrey's comedy
kick not Truman Show and stuff like that
but as comedy characters are all a
little not meaner but a little more
sinister yeah maybe that doesn't work
with elf yeah they're like Bugs Bunny
yeah yeah yeah all right well who was
the 80s comedy star that would have been
in the 80s Alfred that have been Eddie
Murphy's elf John Candy John Kander of
those yeah Eddie Murphy's out further
than a totally coming to America elf
yeah gosh I don't know you tell us who
would elf be throughout the decades yes
all right let's get going or that buddy
has about three years left until the
diabetes takes in so what possibly we
talked about this where cuz he's a human
Oh physiologically or is he but then he
also is capable of like whipped like the
snowballs like he but that's his only
it's his only feat of elf strength
otherwise it's really just like a strong
work ethic at one point one exact point
exhibits elf strength and abilities yes
also apparently the digestive system of
an elf because the preferences yeah I
don't know no Hugh but there's there's
no other food in the North Pole right
obviously no so he's subsisted entirely
candy yet appears to have be perfectly
healthy well I don't know we don't know
we'll try was actual age in this movie
he might be a child he might be like 16
just how the diet and otherwise there's
just a lot of there's like a whole beast
or that cut out of this movie where he's
just like just constantly crapping blood
and having a lot of problems about 15
minutes maybe all the scenes are is
crapping blood you know we were proud of
those shots and we're really the work
that we'll do a small crew they do blur
the lines though one that's convenient
between oh you're healthy even yeah well
maybe the in the same way Deadpool's
doing like the pg-13 retelling there
should do the r-rated retelling elf
yeah with a different children's book oh
yeah I know well that one's free let's
keep going the trail of Christmas and
Phil where the holiday is all about the
resurrection as you can getting too
drunk at work
fighting with your family and hoarding
toys made our season horrible working
conditions but most of all it's about
having faith in a higher power you know
the bearded guy from up above from this
to Iron Man and the station agent guy
who go from this to Game of Thrones
because everyone in it is talented and
deserves the best in life what did you
think I was just gonna savage elf this
movie is delightful I'm not a monster
all the dead you went easy on else yeah
we did kidding me yeah we went easy on
elf what are you we're not there's a
again there's a misconception about what
we're doing here mmm
too much preaching I'm here to [ __ ] on
everything yeah
far from it we're there to give the give
the the unvarnished truth with some
jokes and sometimes we really like the
movie and we'd say it and add some jokes
and oh boy there are some things to pick
on that if we pointed them out in the
movie would've really just collapsed
everybody's enjoyment of it not really
yeah some things but yeah that's what
this show is for yeah we're here to
nitpick to pause and say you know
actually it's arm spins too fast for a
human yeah there's the structure to our
videos it's not just like a running list
of things it's like there's themes and
you know it's not just like I have a
litany of grievances and here we go
[Laughter]
a Manic Pixie dream girl is coming
sidekicks Jeff Bezos and sent his slaves
a Christmas feral nice yeah you sure had
nothing to do with the fact that I was
naked in the shower
I don't know three bangs oh yeah I'm
calling shenanigans on that one buddy
yeah know what you did that's why he's
the dirty up yeah I think we've led one
point we talked about how many scenarios
in this movie this is literally the only
time that it doesn't end in a murder
yes yeah when a guy shows up at his
long-lost father is at office and an elf
costume elf costume saying that like I'm
your son yeah ninety-nine times out of a
hundred except for this one time one of
the two of them is going to die yeah the
same as creepy guy in elf costume enters
women's locker room and sings duet yeah
that's psycho I think that evolved into
the Joker Betty came from like creepy
murderer too the whole premise is creepy
yeah they actually reshot that shower
thing is in the original version of it
he's already in the bathroom desperately
trying to have a healthy back I knew
that was good yeah aren't they also
singing the creepiest Christmas Oh baby
it's called a yeah it's the creepiest
scene singing the creepiest song am I
being detained
[Laughter]
don't don't do the genius lyrics
breakdown on that one it's just a lot
less magical yeah
let's there was other things I want to
say but I think we did him in the other
tag so let's do let's take those three
sizes that day great
Bernard what rescue which is my favorite
Disney movie wheelbarrows mom in every
movie is mr. dacies be teen Siri is that
snow you know the new Grove we also
figured oh I'll tell you I travel
seven levels of the candy cane forest
'passed the sea of twirly-swirly
gumdrops and then i walked through the
lincoln tunnel one does not simply walk
through the lincoln tunnel and so me
monopoly his parker brothers just a
shell corporation and who the parents
think is putting presents under the tree
yeah i guess if we were to nitpick about
the metaphysical reality in which this
movie takes place
it's that let's do a Santa is real
mm-hmm
elves making toys name-brand toys
name-brand toys what happens on
Christmas
why don't adults believe in Santa Claus
right it's the same at the Santa Claus
with an E the movie mm-hmm has the same
problem which is that you have adults
that don't believe in Santa and yet
children who have had Santa Claus hmm
come and the adults are not mystified as
to how the presidents got there so is
there like a confundus charm that Santa
puts on the parents to make them think
that they call the it's called aged and
presents now I guess I totally nailed it
yeah yeah yeah yeah in between uh work
rages and that's why they don't have any
more Christmas yeah right spark if the
etch-a-sketch is made by the elves yes
then who do all of the people who work
for the real life it just gets company
will work that's just going through the
motions they don't know who's doing the
work because I don't know I guess that's
all I know are all of the toy companies
shell corporations for a larger elf plot
yeah I think that they have the entire
industry
it's just dummy Corp sand and it's just
like illegal yeah or a Boros of
corporations owning other ones that
until you get back to the North Pole
yeah the Illuminati or not notorious tax
shelter yep definitely it's a similar
it's a similar question to the one
raised by the 80s movie Santa Claus the
movie which if you've not seen as one of
the most insane movies ever made where
Santa Claus makes like all old-fashioned
toys and like and that seems to me that
all the kids
get so it's like we just live in a
universe where kids only get wooden 18th
century toys or is there like a hybrid
thing yeah if you haven't seen Santa
Claus the movie it stars Dudley Moore
John Lithgow oh this and the actor who
played The Big Lebowski like the actual
Big Lebowski from the big limo David
Weston okay huh and it's basically
Dudley Moore invents candy canes that
make you fly and John Lithgow was an
evil tycoon who rips him off and it goes
from there I'm wrong and they become
spontaneously combustible and they
explode whoa is crazy okay let me check
that out and it's a Coca Cola
I believe it's Coke endorsement deal so
like the kids in the movie are always
drinking coke cool constantly yeah well
that might be I'll dig it up and eat it
but like I think like two years ago we
did it pretty good here's a bunch of
psychotic Christmas movies list and that
was on there and then there's another
low-budget horror one called like elves
you can only watch it on YouTube now
that's crazy
Krampus obviously Santa's sleigh yes ly
with Bill Goldberg have you seen that
yep the cold-open of that is like a
Christmas dinner and it's like Fran
Drescher and Chris Kattan and James Caan
and yeah like they always have Christmas
together
Goldberg comes in and kills all the food
yeah man yeah it's pretty great it's a
Krampus type movie yeah yeah but was
that actual Santa Claus that talk splint
he's sassy sassy Santa yeah yeah cool
all right well this one has um we forgot
to point out Ralphy from a Christmas
story is one of the elves
he and Favreau are working together yeah
with fabric your pals they're their co
coworkers yeah he like he's a director
he directed he directed made maybe I
don't know he directed he did John
pepper direct may thought he did that
cuz he didn't do swingers Peter
Billingsley from A Christmas Story and
Jon Favreau I know they work together
they wrote something together a Peter
Billings you directed something that
Favreau wrote I I don't know but yeah
it's crazy there they go way back
what uh what elf Easter eggs do you
think he's gonna put in the mandalorian
it's a good question that'll be a
different video it screams Amanda Laurie
elf
yeah the Mendel Oriole I think he
definitely eats like he mixes like blue
syrup on blue spaghetti yeah why could
you eat spaghetti through a Mandalorian
armor because it doesn't have vent yeah
yeah you got a really suck hard to get a
spaghetti through the vent yeah but you
could do it I'd like to see a cosplayer
try yeah I would like to see a kidnap
sock Star Wars podcast settled after you
settle that okay I always even missed it
I always assumed the black part just
like flipped up you can just like you
know yeah like you still have to be like
through the let's get a fork in there
these are the questions we ask ourself
yeah serious business less serious will
be next week where we will be running
right back here to this spot to do
another honest trailer commentary and we
hope you will run to your laptops to
check it out yeah yeah that's all we're
gonna give you that's all you get thanks
for sticking around we'll see you then
my late
you
[Music]